je vais vous dire l'absolue vérité celui
vérité sur mon compte je suis né dans
une famille très fortunés sont tous sont
morts aujourd'hui hélas tu m'écris dans
toutes les capitales européennes à
collectionner les pierres précieuses à
chasser le gros gibier à pas et puis la
guerre a éclaté gerani
tous les gouvernements alliés m'ont
remis une décoration aux commandants jay
gatsby pour acte de bravoure
exceptionnelle
et oui est ce que tout ça était vrai
gatsby
un espoir extraordinaire l'animé et
j'avais la sensation gênante qu'il
dissimulait des secrets
kaspi j'aimerais bien savoir qui est cet
homme qui fait ce qu'il fait j'étais à
mon excellente amie monsieur meyer
wolschheim
alors comme ça vous cherchez à vous
faire des relations
se trouve que c'est confidentiel
vous comprenez je suis enchanté de vous
revoir un sait que pat chute n
est ce en lui
une mode de même je suis enchanté de
pouvoir et
6 avant de fuir j'ai appris une chose
renversante
tout s'éclaire maintenant on ne revit
pas le passé on ne revit pas le passé
mais bien sûr que si